it says find the exact value and then
they give you this mess right so this is
what we need to do okay the easiest way
to approach it is to think of this guy
in here right to think of him as an
angle right I know it's really just a
number but if we think of it as an angle
that's useful to us let's call him
Zidane okay so I'm gonna introduce this
variable actually not a variable it's a
constant okay so if that's assignee most
of a feel okay because a fit is within
the domain of service that's all okay
right I can just take sine of both sides
that works so this line here this gives
me a triangle this gives me a triangle
and the reason why a triangle is useful
is because it will give me other trig
ratios to do with theta not just sign
okay so if I put theater over here
what does the one-fifth tell me what can
i label on their sign is obvious an iPod
news isn't it
so the one over five which from
Pythagoras tells you the other side is
square root of 24 five squared minus one
squared
okay so I've got this set up that's
great how am I going to use it if this
is Theta right there this is to thinner
up here it's just double angle double
angle I know double angle is that's two
son cause okay
now you can see why the triangle is
helpful right I already know what sign
is because I defined it I introduced
theater in the first place so it's a bit
but what's cause well now I need to
appeal to this triangle that I've built
right cos is adjacent over hypotenuse
sorry
now I just need to tidy up I might as
well that square root of 24 I can
simplify that right
what would I make that take out a factor
4 that's 2 at 6 at B so you're gonna get
for it 625 and your home okay